cinq candidats également pour ces
élections municipales à plaisir bonsoir
joséphine coleman bergès dans sa maire
sortant de la ville vous êtes la tête de
liste de plaisir avant cette campagne du
premier tour qui arrive donc à sauter
d'un gie -4 avant le scrutin quel bilan
vous faites de cette campagne menée à
plaisir je fais un bilan d'étonnement
par rapport à la teneur de cette
campagne
moi j'ai toujours évoqué le fait que je
suis dans un respect total de la
démocratie et surtout des listes qui se
présentent face à nous avec des valeurs
je dirais pérenne que l'on voit au fur
et à mesure des années cette année c'est
une co était une campagne très violente
très difficile et surtout je trouve axé
sur ma personne et des attaques très
violentes sur ma propre personne je
trouve ça un petit peu dommage parce que
je pense que la période d'une campagne
était une période où on doit bien
évidemment plutôt dire ce que l'on veut
faire et où du projet de long-courrier t
as mise en avant
je ne les ai pas vus en tout cas ce que
j'ai vu j'avais l'impression de les
connaître déjà puisque ce sont des
choses que nous défendons depuis de
nombreuses années ce sont des sujets que
nous avons évoquées lors de nos
différents réunion et conseils
municipaux puisque je veux dire
aujourd'hui
ne serait-ce que le programme que nous
nous présentons c'est un programme sur
lequel on travaille depuis longtemps
dans le cadre de séminaires ou dans le
cadre de travail avec mon équipe et est
ce que pour vous d'être et terminer
cette campagne est ce qu'il va se
poursuivre jusqu'au dernier moment que
vous autorise justement la loi écoutez
nous on a énormément travaillé on a été
sur sur le terrain on a été au devant
des habitants des énormes aimant de
réunions chez l'habitant puisque si elle
quelque chose que je mets en place
depuis très très longtemps
moi j'aurais tendance à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on a plutôt un sentiment
de sérénité que je voudrais remettre
parce que nous on a essayé de faire une
campagne positive vraiment dans la
dynamique et dans l'énergie que nous
avons toujours eu bien sûr
la campagne se termine vendredi soir
donc on est sur le terrain on est
toujours là on est toujours présent mais
bon je veux dire aujourd'hui je pense
que les électeurs ont déjà fait leur
choix et pourquoi vous être de nouveau
justement engagés dans cette démarche
ont presque vous si vous êtes réélu ce
serait votre deuxième mandat
complet à plaisir vous avez été une
première fois en 2012 mais là ce sera le
deuxième mandat complet vous savez un
mandat c'est le moment où on installe
les choses c'est un certain moment où on
se rend compte effectivement des grandes
possibilités que l'on a sur une commune
où comme une aussi forte que celle de
plaisir donc on a enclenché toute une
série de grands projets structurants
comme par exemple le centre bourg qui
n'est pas anodin également l'éco
quartier du val hibou également la zone
high-tech au niveau de saint quentin l2
et de la zone de 5 à pauline ce sont des
projets tellement structurants que il
faut du temps pour les enclenché et puis
il faut les accompagner donc celle
dynamique que nous avons mis en place
d'ailleurs à donner une image
complètement différente à plaisir vous
le voyez bien l'installation l'air les
30 qui bien sûr peut être critiqué en
tout cas apporté une vraie nature
différente à plaisir on a apporté aussi
je pense une forme je dirais de de
douceur notre ville aussi et de
dynamique c'est ce qu'on nous dit et
puis comme je demande aux gens qu est ce
qui vous manque à plaisir véritablement
bien sûr qu'ils manquent les médecins
mais est ce que vraiment je dirais la
ville est dans cette dynamique de
pouvoir trouver des médecins du jour au
lendemain aujourd'hui on en a trouvé
aujourd'hui j'annonce d'ailleurs que
nous avons depuis de nombreuses années
mis en place des activités très forte et
des relations importantes avec les
hôpitaux et avec des médecins et
aujourd'hui on peut annoncer que la
ruche et là que nous avons déjà quatre
médecins présents de généralistes qui
vont arriver un gynécologue qui va
arriver et d'autres groupes de médecins
qui sont déjà dans le travail avec moi
ou au niveau de l'hôpital et du
directeur de l'hôpital
voilà pour cette thématique et qui est
l'un des enjeux de campagne forcément
plaisir un autre enjeu c'est l'écologie
dont on parle dans toutes les villes
vous intégrez vous aussi dans plusieurs
axes de votre campagne notamment la
ville responsable vous souhaitez que la
ville aille vers le zéro carbone qu'on
sait que c'est possible
aller vers le zéro carbone touquet en
avoir l'ambition possible ce serait
ambitieux dans le sens un peu
impertinent même de ma part on n'est pas
les seuls
vous savez bien que le carbone s'arrête
pas aux frontières de plaisir donc on a
mis en place toute une série d'actions
vous voyez bien dans la ville nature
dans notre programme et dans la ville
responsable on a toute une série
d'actions nous avons déjà fait des
actions n'est pas je dirais aujourd'hui
dans une
annonce tout à coup comme ça qui sort du
chapeau parce que c'est la mode nous ne
serait-ce que le résop que nous avons
mis en place la chaleur propre qui est
aujourd'hui qui vient de l'usiné
d'incinération
nous l'avons rajouter sur 6 km et
aujourd'hui c'est effectivement quelque
chose qui est très important sur notre
territoire
il n'y a pas que ça ça fait des années
que l'on met en place toute une série
d'actions et puis comme on parle aussi
de cette circulation 12 qui est
fondamental notre étude est terminée
l'étude est terminée nous a permis de
voir que l'on peut faire sur plaisir
plus de 24 km
il faudra du temps vous savez quand on
promet quelque chose il faut être
capable de se dire qu'on a les moyens de
les faire et aujourd'hui les
collectivités ont des moyens qui sont
les leurs et elles sont aussi limiter
les baisses de dotations sont archi
présent il faut être conscient de ça il
faut être responsable
il faut connaître les dossiers ce qui
n'est pas le cas de toutes les personnes
qui se présentent aujourd'hui parce que
quand il ya des personnes qui se
présentent et qui n'ont jamais été là
qui n'ont jamais été sur le terrain qui
aujourd'hui peuvent critiquer des choses
dans lesquelles il est et je dirais même
partenaire mais qui effectivement
aujourd'hui critique parce que effet
thème que l'idée est venue de nous c'est
assez inquiétant de voir je dirais que
la politique est prise comme un jeu la
politique n'est pas un jeu
la politique il faut avoir de
l'expérience de l'an viii mai de l'an
viii sincère et puis aussi de
l'abnégation parce que c'est de plus en
plus difficile la population a besoin
qu'on les accompagne
on est dans une période assez anxiogène
vous le savez et si vous le permettez je
les condamne à chuter quelque chose ce
qui me semble assez fou c'est que l'on
nous fasse un procès d'intention sur le
travail qu'on n'aurait pas fait au
niveau de cette problématique que pour
un live vous parlais justement du
coronavirus on sait que la participation
à plusieurs pour les dernières élections
de 2014 vous avez été élu dès le premier
tour était d'un peu plus de la moitié
des des plaisirs wwa est ce qu'il ya une
crainte sur le fait que coronavirus
influe sur la participation qui viennent
moins de plaisir war en l'occurrence qui
se déplace aux yeux si ce qu'on entend
mais
contrario je dirais plutôt de mettre la
peur auprès des plaisirs ouah je
voudrais leur dire que toutes les
précautions étaient prises depuis bien
longtemps des élections ça se prépare
des mois al avance on sait depuis
longtemps qu'il va y avoir les élections
donc dans la mesure bien sûr de nos
responsabilités avec les indications
préfectoral et de l'utah nous avons
depuis longtemps prévu et mis en place
toute une série d'actions et on espère
bien que les plaisirs aux avants nous
faire confiance pour venir voter c'est
important de venir peut-être justement
sur ce premier tour puisque on a la
sensation que les choses vont aller en
s'empirant mais en tout cas au niveau de
plaisir je peux vous dire qu'on a un
contrôle permanent au niveau de tous les
équipements des écoles et surtout des
bureaux de vote où on a mis en place
beaucoup de choses qui vont permettre de
rassurer les gens donc venez voter voter
ce que ce qui vous semble le mieux mais
venez voter c'est important
merci joséphine coleman berger maire
sortante de plaisir tête de liste de
plaisir avancé face à vous patrick
jeantet rani un jour elle crie ou a
admis djamel niati également jean-louis
m et relais